mich hat heute auch ein thema bewegt und
zwar die sondierungen der ampel oder
besser formuliert was dort vielleicht
beschlossen werden kann und zwar ist
dass die legalisierung von cannabis
alles sieht eigentlich danach aus dass
mit der ampel die legalisierung von
cannabis kommt ich bin dagegen ich
möchte nicht dass cannabis salon fähig
ist ich möchte nicht dass damit die
verbundene kiffer persönlichkeit die ich
auch persönlich so oft bei menschen
gemerkt habe dieses tun salon fig wird
ich bin dagegen dass wir in deutschland
cannabis legalisieren und hoffe dass die
ampel es nicht tun wird auch wenn jetzt
alles danach aus
ja es ist eher ungewöhnlich ist es mir
noch ist mir schon lange nicht mehr
geschehen als ich dir widersprechen
möchte denn das
ist ein sehr komplexes thema aber es
gibt natürlich ein grund warum die
legalisierung interessant sein könnte es
geht nämlich darum dass man dadurch den
schwarzmarkt austrocknen kann da was im
moment haben die gesetzeslage im moment
nichts anderes als ein großes
konjunkturprogramm für die libanesische
mafia das heißt es gibt zig tausende
allein in der schweiz möchte in berlin
zig tausende konsumenten die das alle
auf der straße irgendwo kaufen zu
minderer qualität zu hohen preisen und
das geld geht direkt in die indy in die
tasche von mafiösen strukturen das ist
ein unglaubliches konjunkturprogramm
wenn man das so machen würde zum
beispiel wie in kanada das man in
apotheken
cannabis anbietet dann hat man erstens
die qualität im blick kann dadurch die
gefahr durch von psychosen zum beispiel
der die diese hochgezüchteten schwarz
erhältlichen cannabis sorten eher
gefährlich ist das könnte man doch nicht
in griff kriegen also in apotheken
gibt es ja auch andere rauschmittel die
dann die dann verschreibungspflichtig
sein müssten und dann würden ab dem
moment wäre not stimmung in der
libanesischen mafia beide würden eine
ihrer haupt
gegen geld bezugsquellen oder alt und
eigentlich als sehr etwa weil die uns
vor dem walisischen mafia nein ich sage
ja ist ja ein sehr komplexer komplexes
thema ich sehe natürlich die gefahren
von von cannabis und ich sage nicht
immer ist es auch tatsächlich so dass
die
das süchtig machen der oder rauschmittel
des rauschmittels
thc was in diesen cannabis drin ist ist
in den letzten 20 30 jahren enorm
gestiegen das heißt wenn du vor 30
jahren gekauft hast war das überhaupt
nicht so gefährlich wie das heute ist
wenn heute 17-jährige 18 jährige zudem
hoch thc
hochdosierten gramm marihuana greifen
ist es hochgefährlich mal weist man weiß
inzwischen absolut dass ein regelmäßiger
konsum von diesem hoch gezüchteten
chemisch hochgezüchteten zeug das man
überall auf der straße bekommt bei
jungen leuten zu vielen fällen zu
starten psychosen führen kann und
schweren gesundheitlichen schäden also
das ist ja gar nicht gefragt gerade
jetzt nur zweiter sein sonst werden wir
beide weil wir so gerne diskutieren hier
noch eine zwei runden bleiben wir gehen
weiter zulässig wie gerade das
kanadische beispiel nicht wirklich
überzeugend der staat hat ist nicht
ansatzweise geschafft den schwarzmarkt
auszutrocknen wir haben jetzt
nebeneinander bestehen einen
florierenden schwarzmarkt mit weitgehend
verschnitten zum teil sehr gefährlich
verschnitten
cannabisprodukten weil einfach die
gewinnspanne dann größer ist und einen
staat der versucht im wettbewerb über
die apotheken mitzuhalten das hat alles
überhaupt nicht geklappt im übrigen
frage ich mich über welchen markt reden
wir hier eigentlich wie viele leute
kiffen eigentlich in deutschland gibt es
darüber erhebung also ist es der bauer
von nebenan der zwischen schwein und
esel hin und wieder mal sind sich was
reinzieht oder ist es eine kleine
großstadt klientel die gerne hier und da
mal high ist das wollen sie gerne tun
eigenbedarf ist jetzt schon straffrei
aber ich sehe überhaupt keine
notwendigkeit darin dass irgendwie zu
legalisieren ich gebe dir in einem punkt
recht ist es mit sicherheit ein
nischenthema ein thema was in der bubble
der großstädterin und rosetta vorkommt
auf twitter
war es die ganze woche über auf platz
eins oder zwei es wurde sehr intensiv
darüber diskutiert aber jeder der social
media ein bisschen kennt weiß wer es auf
twitter unterwegs ist sind die leute die
in der medienbranche irgendwie interesse
haben die in der politik unterwegs sind
es ist tatsächlich ein stück weiter
babbel thema ich würde der nähe aber
auch gerne wieder sprechen und hätte
einen anderen punkt es sind ja nicht nur
die großen clans die die mafia
strukturen die in diesem geschäft
mitmischen sondern sind auch eine ganze
menge kleindealer ist sind leute die
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel zu hause
haben was über den eigenbedarf hinaus
geht und es gibt politikerinnen eine
fällt mir besonders ein von den grünen
sie ist polizistin irene mihalic heißt
sie und sie sagt eine rückständige
drogenpolitik die führt zu einer
überlastung der justiz und der
strafverfolgungsbehörden sollen wir
wirklich viel geld dafür ausgeben haben
unsere polizisten nicht wichtigeres zu
tun als solche kleinkriminellen zu
also das ist in der tat einer der
wichtigsten punkte das weiß ich übrigens
auch aus gespräch mit polizeibeamten vor
ort die sagen hier werden wahnsinnig
viele ressourcen investiert die wir auch
besser einsetzen könnten warum sollen
wir uns mit sagen wir mit so einem
nischenthema an der stelle beschäftigen
übrigens es ist ja nicht so wir reden ja
hier über eine kontrollierte freigabe ab
18 darüber reden wir es ist ja nicht so
dass demnächst überall leute stehen und
von mir aus und beim neusser
schützenfest und cannabis verkaufen
sondern es wird stellen geben die
lizenzen bekommen müssen vom staat die
dann auch unter bestimmten strengen
voraussetzungen cannabis dann verkaufen
das heißt auch ein gesundheits argument
der dealer interessiert sich nicht für
die qualität der kann die produkte
strecken sehr interessiert sich nicht
dafür aber die gefährdet die gesundheit
der leute gefährdet ja oder nein aber
wenn das eine staatlich kontrollierte
stelle ist dann kann man immer davon
ausgehen dass dieser aspekt zumindest an
der stelle berücksichtigen falls er
das gesagt hat so ein parallel martin
stehen tatsächlich war das beispiel kann
ein suboptimaler könnte auch nach
holland schauen das problem ist wenn
dann wird sich ein illegaler markt und
ein staatlicher markt einander
existieren dann ist es eigentlich
niemanden geholfen vor allem der konsum
nach oben gehen und wurde sofort auch
sorge habe und da stimme ich die
wiederum zu die gesellschaftliche
aktuellen tätigkeit das
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz von
gefährlichen rauschmitteln ist ein
problem das ist ein problem das wollen
wir jetzt ganz kurz darauf hinweisen
darf das holländische modell stellt den
handel straffrei aber nicht die
produktion da ist also noch sehr viel
spielraum für schwarz hersteller die das
dann irgendwie im wege der der produkt
manipulationen in den markt einspeisen
ich wundere mich ein bisschen dass das
neusser schützenfest unter drogen
politischen aspekten so ein bedeutender
umschlagplatz offensichtlich ist ein
fiktives beispiel
aber ja ich habe auch andererseits ein
logisches problem da der missbrauch der
anderen legalen drogen tabak und alkohol
ja ein riesen gesellschaftliches problem
ist was berechtigt uns dann zu der
hoffnung dass die legalisierung einer
weitere ja das ist der punkt dazu
richtig tollen ergebnissen führt wir
haben sie sind inzwischen so weit dass
wir ribery wenn wir die er selbst
scanner kasse einzahlen freigeben lassen
müssen vom ladenpersonal mundwasser muss
zum teil frei gegeben weil spuren von
alkohol drin sind es hilft nichts gegen
missbrauch und die riesen kosten für das
gesundheitssystem ja weil sie die droge
aber wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf
zumindest da auch dazu gibt es studien
als deutlich risikoärmer gilt zumindest
für erwachsene und über nichts anderes
reden wir ja hier es soll der verkauf
erfolgen an menschen über 18 und es ist
also deutlich weniger riskant als
alkohol oder tabak es gibt keinen
einzigen bestätigten fall dass jemand
gestorben ist war das zu viel cannabis
konsumiert hat bei alkohol und sehen wir
erst da gibt's dann gegenargument und
das mache ich jetzt gern bringen ich
habe ein maastricht studiert ja und da
gibt es ganz viel coffeeshops damit viel
gekifft das heißt ich kenne auch viele
leute kennengelernt die gekifft haben in
der uni waren diese leute deutlich
schlechter als sie dies nicht getan
haben die personell sie wahr das hab ich
wirklich in maastricht damals sehr stark
kennengelernt weil damals wirklich viele
gekippt das muss man einfach offen sagen
die persönlichkeit dieser leute war
komplett anders es war eine kiffer
persönlichkeit hört sich jetzt komisch
an die leute sind lethargisch die sind
nicht energiegeladen die schaffen ihre
uni nicht das heißt es muss ja nicht
immer erst der tod sein dass man sagt
eine droge tut einem menschen was an und
ich kann sagen nach meiner erfahrung in
holland ich möchte nicht dass diese
käfer persönlichkeit in deutschland
salonfähig ist irgendwie trinker
persönlichkeit und besser das problem
ist ich glaube mein ein glas wein zum
beispiel abend trinkt oder wenn man zwei
joints raucht mittags also ich habe
damals die erfahrung persönliche
erfahrung sind immer schlecht weil es
stammtischniveau ist aber ich habe
damals die erfahrung gemacht dass die
jungs den zwei gläser wein am abend
betrunken oder vielleicht auch mal mit
drei eingedrungen haben die uni genauso
geschafft haben wie ich und dass die
kiffer die uni nicht geschafft haben und
vielleicht kennst du ja auch leute die
kiffen die kiffer persönlichkeit die
wüsste jetzt nicht absprechen die gibt
es definitiv auch studiert bin auch mit
leuten in kontakt kommen weiterhin mit
sicherheit so was auch zu beobachten war
aber ich glaube aber
sehr erfolgreich mächtigen sagen eine
kiefer aber das ist glaube ich ein
abriss die macht
das
[Musik]